you
ok
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen as
dean of the Graduate School of Business
it's my great pleasure and my great
privilege to welcome you to this diploma
awards ceremony of our weekend
graduation exercises our purpose this
afternoon is to introduce and to honor
the graduates from our four different
degree programs but we also gather to
honor the families the friends of our
graduates who are here to celebrate them
as well I'm pleased that so many members
of the Stanford community can join me on
the stage here this afternoon we have
former Trustees members of our Advisory
Council we have a number of
representatives from our administrative
staff all over the ground the people who
really support and operate all our
programs and of course a very large
contingent of our faculty are on the
stage in our school is a partnership in
the promotion of learning about
management it's a partnership of great
mutual responsibility for the learning
that takes place here and mutual respect
for the role that each other plays in
that learning it's a partnership of
great students and great faculty there's
an old parable that if I catch a fish
for you I feed you for a day but if I
teach you how to fish I feed you for a
lifetime our aim as a faculty has been
to teach you how to approach the
problems the challenges of management in
a way that will last a lifetime there's
no greater joy for a teacher than
students who leave with the confidence
that comes from acquiring true learning
and true learning ability our faculty by
their presence here join in expressing
their congratulations in your
achievements and their confidence in
your futures and I would invite them to
please rise at this time so you might
express your appreciation to them
faculty
thank you very much for that while today
is an occasion of celebration and joy it
is also a time for remembrance and for
sadness sadness for those we wish could
be celebrating with us here today for
many of you that is someone in your life
whose dedication encouragement and
sacrifice made it possible for you to be
here today but for all of us at the GSB
it's particularly sad because we're
missing an MBA class mate Chris Psalm
and two of our first year classmates
viet nuin and micah springer who were
tragically lost to us in a terrible
accident last October will you please
join me in a moment of reflection and
silence in honor of Chris viet Micah and
others in your lives who you want to
remember at this time
thank you
now it's customary at this time for the
Dean to offer a few final words of free
advice I do that with great caution and
humility firstly because at my
graduation now so long ago I can't
remember what the Dean said and secondly
i know we've taught you well that
there's no such thing as free advice so
let me keep your opportunity costs low
and make it very short I'd like to offer
you four simple challenges as you leave
this place challenge number one as new
alumni resolved to be great ambassadors
for Stanford as beautiful as the
surroundings here are Stanford is really
about its people our students faculty
staff past and future who they are what
they do before you came here I'm sure
that you gained an impression of us
based on GSB people that you met or
observed now you become the role models
that others will talk to and look to
informing their impressions about our
school and I hope you'll relish this
responsibility and play this role with
enthusiasm and pride pride that you've
had an exceptional experience here one
that many coveted but only a few
received and you're now the product of
that experience and a life member of a
great community that I shared this
experience as Dean I've been an official
ambassador these past ten years but you
and I can now both play unofficially
that role every day in so many ways so
be a great ambassador for the Stanford
GSB in your words and in your deeds
challenge number two
remember your academic roots which you
shaped and strengthened here you leave
here a different person than when you
arrived with a changed perspective a new
way of thinking you've acquired a
knowledge base that's built on very
strong foundations about how economies
work how markets function how firms
operate how people behave how and why
organizations perform well this is a
knowledge base that will enable you to
to embrace and deal confidently with the
many changes that will confront you and
challenge you it can keep you
intellectually honest it can keep others
honest and if you nurture it through
continued learning serious efforts to
apply it and then reflect on those
efforts you'll make a lifelong gift to
yourself so keep investing in what
you've started here see that your
academic roots are strong and you never
stop learning third challenge resolve to
make giving and community building an
important part of your lives we're only
as strong as the communities in which we
live and work if others don't succeed
you can't either you can't do it alone
it said that much is expected from those
to whom much has been given and you are
a group who's been given a lot so give
of your time give of yourself of your
financial resources give because you're
blessed because you can and because you
must if you're really to build the
meaning in your life that can only come
from supporting things greater than
yourself experience the wisdom of
Emerson who observed that it is one of
the most beautiful compensations of life
that no man can sincerely try to help
another without helping himself so make
giving and community building an
important part of your life
and continue the great tradition you've
already started with your
record-breaking class gift one class
many voices a hundred percent you are
great community builders already and the
school and I are deeply grateful and the
fourth and final challenge stretch
yourself stretch yourselves each of you
has so much more potential than you can
possibly imagine we've tried hard to
stretch you while you're here it's an
amazing thing you know we have alumni
all over the world and to the best of
our knowledge no one has ever come back
and said you pushed me too hard don't
leave it to others don't leave it to
chance stretch yourself in all the
dimensions of your life on the job as a
spouse a partner a parent a child as a
friend as a community member venture
outside your comfort zone that's how you
learn that's how you grow give yourself
a cold call and for your own good and
the good of others take on leadership
responsibilities in whatever your
organization you find yourself play a
role in changing that organization for
the better that's leadership that's how
you learn it up to now you've been
evaluated almost exclusively on what you
know and on your potential but from now
on it will be on what you can actually
do there's a wonderful old Chinese
saying I hear and i forget i see and i
remember but i do and i understand an
understanding is the highest form of
knowledge and learning
and deep understanding is your greatest
asset and advantage so get involved in
doing not thinking about or talking
about or analyzing about but doing that
is how you will gain wisdom and
understanding and that is where you must
stretch yourself and take risks and what
you have learned and acquired here gives
you the ability and the confidence to
take those risks without ever having to
risk your integrity or your reputation
stretch yourself to cite Emerson once
again do not go where the path may lead
go instead where there is no path and
leave a trail so for simple challenges
be a great ambassadors for Stanford
remember and strengthen your academic
roots give back and stretch yourself and
now it's time to present the diplomas
I'd like to first mention a diploma
that's not in the program we call it the
ppt SBS degree putting partner through
Stanford Business School and I'd like to
ask all those partners in our midst to
please stand and I'd like to ask their
partner graduates to please turn and
show your appreciation to those partners
thank you thank you very much and thank
you partners assisting me in the
presentation and remarks about diplomas
and awards are a variety of important
officials listed in your program senior
associate Dean's glenncarroll and David
crepes professors John Roberts James
patel and George Parker Sloane director
Murray makini associate dean Sharon
Hoffman and assistant dean Derek Bolton
and finally dean emeritus arjay miller
the third dean of the fourth dean of the
Stanford Business School will start with
the PhDs and professor Carol Glenn
Thank You Dean Joss it's my honor to
introduce to you today the GSB PhD class
of 2009 over the past four to five years
the women and men who are about to
receive their degrees to become experts
in their chosen academic fields
accounting economics finance marketing
operations information technology
organizational behavior and political
economy we run a small and exclusive
program in a typical year we receive
about six to seven hundred applicants
and we admit only twenty pursuing a
doctorate is a long and difficult
journey filled with uncertainty usually
two years of course work is followed by
two to three years of intensive
individual study of a research topic of
the students choosing by the time the
students finish they are not only
experts in their fields but their self
motivated scholars who are driven mainly
by curiosity and passion undertaking PhD
work is risky but the potential rewards
are enormous not only to the students
but to the GSB and to the larger
academic community and the world some of
these graduates who will walk across the
stage today I have no doubt will become
intellectual leaders in their chosen
fields and many of them will play
important roles in shaping what future
students are taught about business and
management at all levels of the
university and in the corporate world
now as we all know here teaching is
always a joint effort between students
and faculty but faculty and doctoral
students who work together develop a
special kind of personal relationship
that evolves through the students career
it typically starts out with the
professor being the master or expert in
the student as the novice or apprentice
and at some stage in graduate school the
relationship undergoes a transformation
it's difficult to explain it's very hard
to predict but all those of us who've
been advisors have experienced it it's
that moment when the student to faculty
relationship becomes a
ligue de colleague relationship today we
formally celebrate that transition on
the stage here as the advisers come up
and place the hood of the Stanford
Business School on the candidates and
then they join us on stage as we welcome
them into our profession so I will read
the names of the candidates and the
dissertation advisers will come up and
put the hood on them one at a time we'd
like you to hold the applause until the
end if at all possible the first set
candidate is synth choice a wrote
Maria Korea
Nathaniel fast
Edward me Fung
Eric F Forrester
Brett Samuel green
david lowe ski
Cassie mo Gilner Marius florin Nikolas
coo
Monica vaudeville Scott will tur moose
shipping zhang
the Masters of Arts in business research
recognizes the accomplishments of
students who have completed the course
work and fulfilled the research
requirements of the master's degree but
who are not continuing on to do further
work at the phd level graduates
receiving this degree typically pursue
professional careers in research outside
of universities are in management and
other business fields the two candidates
the first is to chuck cabeza Barack Odom
and one final applause for all our
doctorates in MA
the global management program was
instituted by the business school in
1994 it arose actually from a student
initiative and it had three aims one was
to help give greater visibility for the
already significant resources and
attention than being devoted to
international issues in the school the
second was to help students prepare for
careers in management in an increasingly
global economy and the third was to push
the school to do more to connect its
teaching and research to global issues
the program involves both the very
extensive student organized
extracurricular activities and formal
academic elements in particular the
global experience requirement which this
is the first mba class to have done and
the GMP certificate program which
requires students in either the Masters
or MBA or Sloan masters programs to
complete a set of electives related to
international business today we
recognize 81 students in the Sloan and
MBA programs who have met those
requirements during the certificate of
global management their names are
indicated quite appropriately in the
program with a start and they will each
be receiving his or her certificate from
the program director grecia COI after
receiving the degrees from Dean Joss
under the leadership of dean emeritus
arjay miller who is with us today the
GSB created the public management
program in 1971 at its inception the
program focused almost entirely on
government both on the effective
government action on private enterprise
and on the prospect of improving
national and state governments by
training managers for public sector
careers the program maintained that
focus for 15 years then in the late
1980s we significantly expanded the
scope of the PMP both to encompass
growing student interest in managing
not-for-profit entities and equally
importantly to explore the full range of
voluntary action by private citizens in
the past decade that focus has widened
even further to encompass for-profit
social enterprises and as we read
today's headlines it seems that we are
coming full circle with an ever growing
need for economically sound management
skills in national and state government
especially here in California we are
proud of the graduates who devote their
careers to government service and to
nonprofit management but I assure you
that we are equally proud of our
graduates who while pursuing careers in
the private sector also volunteered to
serve on school boards government
Commission's or as trustees directors or
advisors to a wide range of social
artistic or philanthropic ventures I
will hold a special place in my heart
for those who use their Excel modeling
and operations skills to marshal their
forces as coaches of their children's
soccer basketball or lacrosse teams
David crepes and I can send you our
spreadsheets
I also will remind you that the Stanford
GSB was the first University student
group of any sort to start its own I
have a dream chapter while it is my hope
that through its seemingly innumerable
co-curricular activities that PMP has
touched the lives of all GSB students at
graduation it is particularly
appropriate to recognize those students
who in addition to earning their MBA
degrees or their Sloan program
management degrees also have completed a
formal course of study in the management
of public nonprofit and social venture
organizations this year there are 65
recipients of the public management
certificate whose names are listed in
the commencement program I now ask them
to rise and I ask everyone to join with
me in acknowledging their
accomplishments
good afternoon on this festive occasion
the mission of the Stanford Sloan
master's program is to prepare
experienced managers from business and
government for leadership the Sloan
program is a 10-month full-time master's
degree 457 successful executives and
entrepreneurs in mid-career they come
from 18 countries and every region of
the world many of the Sloan fellows are
sponsored by their organizations which
intend them to take on significant
leadership responsibilities when they
return other fellows are self-funded
many of whom are entrepreneurs who plan
to create innovative enterprises after
graduation the Sloan master's program is
an extraordinary opportunity to develop
personal strengths broaden horizons and
expand possibilities in addition to
taking a rigorous academic program Sloan
fellows participate in a series of
leadership activities which include
meetings with distinguished national and
international leaders the Sloan class of
2009 will conclude their fellowship year
with an international study trip
departing next week to meet leaders and
to study the economies of Brazil
Argentina and Chile having completed all
the academic requirements of the program
they are here today to be awarded the
degree of Master of Science and
management and to join the worldwide
company of GSB alumni we wish them their
partners and families much success in
the next phase of their lives which we
know will be marked with distinction
professor George Parker who is a sloan
faculty director will read their names
while Dean Joss presents the diplomas
i joined murray and congratulating the
sloan class of 2009 Frederick R bell
ken arima Ariana lale billington Nicola
Wilson blame Mercedes racine yo Tom
Cahill Nicholas cap Tim Carmichael
I vichu Sanjay Don he jose del boca mike
dozer Jonathan Easton andreas foreign
wold shall win full of Valley airy
galitsky
layin elgar saw rash need go L Karthik
Gopal full Kurt graphs my John grabowski
james h Hong
Tom say I think some of these people
were not here when the program started
here cabra elaine johnson young hoon kim
christopher co Sebastian culling prabhat
kumar
Merlin coo st. off Christopher lamb
Robert Lawson boo Cheng Li Shan maduka
John Hikaru matsushima Bree rose mckean
erin moore ranjit ne'er akira nakano she
Jim Neeson Adam park
Catherine Sampson growth now roomie sigh
a key
Nicholas che sandbox sim Ashley Simon's
Alexi star again Michael Stuckey
John Hendrick Tawee son Amanda Tucker
moto hero umehara rizwan q virk victor
wang yu han wong and finally shoo wah jo
congratulations to the Sloan class of
it is now a great honor and privilege to
present to you the Stanford MBA class of
this is the 84th graduating class at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business you
came to us as survivors of an extremely
selective and competitive admissions
process but as I'm sure you will all
agree the hardest thing about the
Stanford MBA was not getting in you
survived your foundations and
perspectives courses and you even
survived cat perhaps some of you even
enjoyed those courses and you then got
the sample from a rich menu of
challenging electives at the same time
you've had time to engage in personal
growth and reflection about who you are
and where you are going and one of the
things of which we are most proud
concerning the MBA program you gave your
time and energy to the local community
all this is true about you as it has
been true about each of your predecessor
classes but every class is special and
different and in the history of the GSB
the class of two thousand line will be
viewed as very special you are here
during a period of exciting change as we
plan and then began construction of a
new campus and strengthen our ties to
the rest of Stanford but most
significantly you were the pioneer class
of the new MBA curriculum of course
there were some bumps in the road and
truth to tell some of the bumps and
potholes still remain to be smooth and
filled but your efforts and goodwill as
pioneers has earned for the class of two
thousand line the gratitude of the
faculty and staff and a very important
place in the history of the GSP and it's
MBA program we thank you all for all you
did and for the good grace with which
most of the time you did it
as for the future we have high
expectations for each and every one of
you as you embark on the next stage of
your lives but this is not goodbye we
hope and expect you to remain a member
of our community now with the new title
of alumnus but engaged in the same basic
activity of growing personally and
intellectually giving to the community
as you take from it in the next few
minutes we will be reading the names of
the graduates in alphabetical order and
we will invite the graduates forward to
receive their diploma names will be read
by Sharon Hoffman associate dean and
director of the MBA program and by Derek
Bolton assistant dean for mba admissions
and the graduates will receive their
diplomas routine jaws we ask that you
please hold your applause until all the
graduates have received their diplomas
in nine years it never works I would now
like to invite dean emeritus Arjay
Miller to join us arjay miller was the
much and justly admired 4th dean of the
GSB from nineteen sixty eight to
nineteen seventy eight as someone who
joined the GSB during RJ's
administration I can attest to his
sterling leadership during a period of
time when the GSB attained its status as
the premier school of business in honor
of RJ service the top 10% of the class
ranked by academic performance are
designated as RJ Miller scholars as we
read the names of the graduates we will
acknowledge the new Arjay Miller
scholars who will then be congratulated
by the man himself and now Sharon and
Derek would you please begin Blake
sterling
Emily page Adams s adams
rami magdy adeeb Arjay Miller scholar
Sarah Samantha Adler Faisal Ahmed Anna
albir so miento sweat la Alexandra
Kristen altorfer a beak Anand t Coleman
Andrews before
David antosh Arjay Miller scholar Luke
Archer nawaf aroma armando martinez
Arjay Miller scholar Michael Lamar
Armstrong
kaun hai kuch danielle rodriguez de
azevedo Arjay Miller scholar karishma
Bay Jill Emily Baylor Arjay Miller
scholar Michael Bannon RJ Miller scholar
Mateo the Doya Jonathan Diekman
mar 1 George Dajani dress ben amor Eric
thanks son Alex paragraphs key RJ Miller
scholar Allison Bergen drawer Bearman
and Louise Barry Arjay Miller scholar
amanda kay Boaz
and poor debts key ray bradford Arjay
Miller scholar Brittany brag RJ Miller
scholar Scott Gilbert Bromley
lose bay bremond
Patricia Francis Buckley Brenda would
Raja Gayatri would Raja Willard Carlisle
butcher jr. Arjay Miller scholar
alejandro camino george howard caps the
second Arjay Miller scholar Michael in a
car Sean Timothy carrithers Patricio
Casillas Tom sto Nicholas George Hamas
oh sorry Eugene clifton chop
Nicholas George Hamas Stewart James
champion decrepit bupa Chandra Brian
Chang Arjay Miller scholar John Dee de
chatterjee Betty Chen Liang Chen Oh Chen
Simon Chang
Arnold chong see how fun chu Rebecca chu
Josh Cincinnati Matt Collier
Julia Elizabeth Collins Ryan Patrick
Connelly Francisco Cordero thomas andrew
Costin Christopher who halt
Eduardo Alberto Diego Croce belton Alan
cullum the meal delao Arjay Miller
scholar Andy Davis Eric Dayton Logan
Dean's William Benjamin Deckard Aaron
Denman
and bills Divya bahi Michael Thomas dole
is all Matthew Dressler Cole Dudley
Aleksei do not yet yo Han dorami Arjay
Miller scholar Catherine Duryea
Judith Duval orlando eagle alejandro
elizondo Fernandez Catherine enna Chris
Erickson Travis Robert Everton
Elizabeth Aaron Ewing Catalina fajardo
Luna max faltan Jonathan Edward farmer
federico Lozano
Diego feldburg John Fenech jose antonio
Fernandez Justin Phillip Finnegan Kieran
furlong Arjay Miller scholar or ngao
Adrian gamble mengão Mauricio Garcia
manuel garcia Podesta Arjay Miller
scholar Anna Garza munos Castilla
Elizabeth and gas
Bernard gar Terry Geddes Nathan Jared
Glasgow kamal go sir RJ Miller scholar
Irena goldstein Michael golub
gabriela gonzalez stupa ignacio go
rupees Connor Michael Green
Claire Greece
Amy yah goo surely Natalie Guillen
Ishaan gupta
nishita goop day our ahan Karen heart
Fang hey Kyle Hendrickson Chris Herndon
Laura Hines Brad hively Kent king taco
Anita joven Sen
marina Chris tova lauren marie halt RJ
Miller scholar Christine hung Claire
Wray Hunsicker song her
William Michael Hyatt
Marta ibanez noble hero igarashi reiko
mi catherine ii Jackson roshni Jane on
me John Lydia lie jet
Brooke Jones dennis s jones
Laura Rachel Jones Jorge Belden Stephen
jus mark juice michael david kahn Arjay
Miller scholar Megan Emily Camille down
Kang
Sonja Kastner Peter Edward Cavill
Jennifer night Kaiser Christian Keller
Kathryn Faye Kennedy Guzman cephalic on
Darius graves kuraby Daniel Kilpatrick
RJ Miller scholar min jung kim although
ivan king
Timothy Kirby arson sebastian kitsch RJ
Miller scholar Rodney Harrison night
Brian coo
Chris kuranda
Benjamin Cornell Arjay Miller scholar
Ryan cotton steady Jake craft Lois
Turner cranoch
abhishek kumar camille core Macheath
stewart wing Jing Kwok justina t ly
Peter lake Zamir lousy RJ Miller scholar
audrianna let landaverde
Francisco Lorraine Melissa Lassiter
Brett Braden Lawrence benjamin lee bo jo
Ann Lee tay ly
pierre-yves LaGrone sandy shi lin pj
Leonard uchi Arjay Miller scholar Betsy
Lind Lee Charles Linden Nicholas
Laurette min you
Tony Lou Grant Watson live a see
Randall griks Lloyd Francis t lo Milania
lunch Enya Rafael Lopez Espinosa Matthew
send el bloque i'm sarah and luxembourg
michael joseph madden Malika manoharan
Thomas mappin Adam Howard marchek Julia
Marcus George Markov aliza marks Stan
mark Uzi Andrew M Martin
Spencer mon Dana mauriello Lindsay Scott
Maynard Shawn James McCarthy Ian
Roderick mckelvey Christopher Terrence
McNamara samra McCrea Grillo Tom Mercer
Gabrielle makovsky Garrett Benjamin
Miller RJ Miller scholar Jacob Winston
Miller
holla Lord Ares Yazdi
mohammed sad algo gel
Tamim mohsin Charles M more Arjay Miller
scholar vanessa marie Motley andreatta
Lou 40 Peter grosvenor MUNs aghhhh
Andrew James Nash Weber Arjay Miller
scholar justin matthew Nasiri navya
chowdhury
David noon door fur John Richard Darcy
Newcomb hung nuin
Miley when tom m nu n quran miss Jill
siobhan fortune Nolan
Matthew Shay O'Hare I see john owes
llega knocked I gorkem oktai Jacqueline
Patricia auto Leenie Pablo paniagua John
jung-hoon park a meet patel
Brett Paulson
ashley lauren Peyton
christophe penny J Evgeni air vago
George Bailey Payton the fifth Richard
Phillips Astrid Pierre Louie Sophie
Phillips Pinkard Arjay Miller scholar
crass a mere p / cough Michelle trail
Jacqueline Purcell Kristen when Jamie
Raska
sameera rahmatullah an eel rana wat je
charitha Ruth whathe jr. Helen re Evan
matthew rhys Jonathan rhinaman Maureen
Michelle restore Oh Alex Robinson Heidi
Louise Robinson
Lisa Robinson Oscar Gerardo Rojas
Majorca Gabrielle Elaine Franco rose
Lisa Rosencrantz Trevor Ross David
rotblat mio socata Alexander Salazar
Julia Salieri Sonya sup ray robinson
airs Sawyer ellen snyder
are ya schreiber
Claudio Seidler Jose shabbat cherrim
Arjay Miller scholar Daniel John chef
chick
ilya sharik of ways shoe Brendan
Schmidt's Arjay Miller scholar Mario
Cecilia Bernard Michael Anthony Silva
Jenni Murray Skinner Benjamin sloop
Arjay Miller scholar Spencer frances
fisher Smith Lauren Smith hams Vanessa
so Aras
farzad Soleimani Patricios feeler Harry
sreenivasan Luke Jesse Hartley Stewart
David Strasburg
yeah Megan Nicole Stricker
Jennifer's duyvil sudharshan sreenivasan
Alexei super glue andrew william t'aime
Jonathan Emory Tate Stacy McLaughlin
Taylor Andrew George terberg
Alexander tio Rick Toki marrin Thomas
Sarah and Thomas Kevin Thompson Hana to
Alberto sapien tovar hey sy
Robin sigh Judy sow
Anna ty drew you were Jeremy Daniel
Utley Arjay Miller scholar Elizabeth
vadas d Earl Martin saweet valença
Thomas Arthur vents tavern Javier
Velasquez Lopez
liana Valentina vetter Arjay Miller
scholar day an even off the beaten off
Michael David rana Robert durian bremen
Linnet bagger
nasrin wobba Lisa yuan wang gap 10 sorry
cool Carrie Colette wise
Tim Whelan Gavin Williams Erica Stacey
Williamson Natasha Wilson Mac enough
Stephanie Patricia Wilson Justin Gordon
Whismur Justin taco wrong Gary yang
Allison Yazdi in life ye Joey yeni
Christopher gyeongmin yep RJ Miller
scholar Steven shoe un Angela say asif
zoom on
rahel EO zambrano munther zadan Jin yuan
shang Rachel Naomi zimet RJ Miller
scholar
and one Pablo zoria
well congratulations to all the
graduates of all four of our programs
you're terrific and it's a wonderful day
of celebration it's now time in our
program for the announcement of several
individual MBA student awards but before
we turn to those Awards I want to take a
moment to acknowledge and thank the
person who introduced our MBA graduating
class professor David crepes is
completing nine years of service to the
school as our senior associate dean now
during that time he has been directly
responsible for oversight of the MBA
program David is a world renowned
economist with amazing talents he's
contributed so much of his time his
energy his intellect his personal
integrity to the quality of this program
and all of us who observe him are in awe
of his accomplishments people say a lot
of nice things about the stanford
business school today but i can tell you
there's absolutely no question we would
not be where we are without the
tremendous contribution that david has
made and i would just like here to
express publicly my deepest thanks to
him for his efforts these nine years and
ask that all of you might join me in
expressing the appreciation of the
entire GSB community
thank you very much thank you now I'll
turn to the arbuckle award the Arbuckle
Awards a very special one at our school
it's given every year to an MBA student
chosen by the classmates of that student
it's named for a very special person
Ernest see Arbuckle he was Dean here
from nineteen fifty eight to nineteen
sixty eight Ernie was my Dean and it was
during his deanship that the school
began its rise to prominence as a
world-leading school here to introduce
the award and announce its winner is
Ernie and Kitty's youngest child please
welcome Susan Arbuckle Susan
I'm always proud to be here on behalf of
my dad Stanford University and the
people of the business school were dear
to his heart and integral to his life
for decades from his days as an
undergrad an MBA student Dean and
trustee nominated and chosen by his or
her peers the recipient of the Ernest e
arbuckle award is the second year
student who by his or her active
participation initiative leadership and
personal integrity is judged as having
contributed most to the fulfillment of
the goals of the Graduate School of
Business in his or her actions both
within school and society this award is
a student body's way of honoring that
individual who is shared with them a
unique blend of activism and courage and
character from a pool of eight finalists
one named Rose the top but before I tell
you who that person is let me share with
you a few quotes from his or her peers
one of this year's recipients classmates
remarked that this person has done a
truly remarkable job in bringing people
together it never ceases to amaze me the
amount of things this student does every
day to help a fellow classmate in need
another classmate described this person
as giving a daily testimony of charm
good humor hard work and integrity a
personification of the arbuckle award in
our class yet another declared this
student embodies the true collaboration
collaborative spirit of the GSB with a
tireless commitment to the school and to
our classmates having that countless
activities with passion and dedication
this student is said to hold the utmost
respect for both the institution and the
wider community everything that this MBA
student has done over the last two years
has served to raise our prestige both
inside and outside our network set
another student they're all talking
about the warm and engaging hosea
shabbat shalom
as he makes his way up here let me tell
you that one of the most active members
of the class Jose or Pepe as he is known
was co-president of the global
management program led a study trip to
Israel led the cause for the Tabasco
flood and organized and coach people for
the talk o nines among many other
endeavors to his credit back home he
also created a nonprofit educational
foundation to raise the aspirations and
schooling levels of Mexican construction
workers in an effort to transform
inequitable aspects of the industry and
move it toward greater stability
congratulations
you
established in 1978 the Alexander a robo
check student achievement award is given
to an MBA student selected by the
finance faculty for achievement in
finance courses this award recognizes
professor robo checks outstanding
contribution to the teaching of finance
at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business from 1960 until his death in
1978 the recipient receives an award and
his or her name is engraved on a plaque
displayed in the GSB South building and
I assume the plaque will move when the
campus does this year the winner of the
Robotech award is Billy butcher
among the RJ Miller scholars one
student's academic achievement places
him or her at the top of the class this
student is designated as the Henry Ford
the second scholar and receives along
with the Miller scholar scroll a
substantial cash award and his or her
name is engraved on another plaque
displayed at the GSB South building the
Henry Ford the second scholar for the
class of two thousand nine is Billy
butcher
this is the 10th time that Bob Joss has
presided over the GSP's graduation
ceremony as dean and as I'm sure most of
you know this is the last time he will
do so we've had opportunities to
celebrate at length remarkable
achievements of Bob's deanship but just
to list the highlights building a much
building much stronger ties with the
rest of Stanford University including
the initiation of three new joint degree
programs initiating and moving to
construction an entirely new campus
nearly doubling the scale of our
executive education programs the
build-out of the Center for social
innovation and creation of the Centers
for global management and economy and
for leadership development and research
the design and implementation of a new
MBA curriculum dramatic renewal of the
faculty nearly sixty percent of the
tenure line faculty as of next
September's first were hired during
Bob's tenure and over fifty percent of
full professors as of that they were not
full professors when Bob began the
raising of over seven hundred million
dollars in expendable and capital gifts
and less concretely but probably of
greatest importance being a leading
voice of the idea that the leadership of
managed organizations is a vastly
important and even noble calling this is
a truly remarkable record of achievement
and I ask all of you to join me in
expressing our gratitude to the 8th Dean
of the Graduate School of Business
Robert L jaws
thank you very very much well thank you
for that I didn't see that on the
program David thank you I can tell you
that it has been a labor of love
congratulations to Pepe to Billy to all
the graduates and to their families and
friends here today you know there are
many great things about university
graduations that I love marching in here
i love the traditions the pomp the
ceremony but i think what i like best of
all is that at the end of your time here
in our final act of awarding you
diplomas and bidding you farewell and as
you bid your farewells to your friends
to your surroundings here and you bring
your Stanford experience to an end we
call this ending a commencement a
beginning and indeed it is the start of
a new journey for you from acquiring
knowledge to applying it from building
potential to exercising it from learning
to doing it's the beginning of your new
life after Stanford and for me as well I
join you in taking this next step we
talk here at our school about changing
lives changing organizations changing
the world the lives we have aimed to
change here are your lives so that you
would change the organizations that can
change the world a world that so
desperately needs leadership I know my
life has changed for having been here
and I hope and believe that yours will
be lives more promising and more
fulfilling because of your time with us
and I wish you well and now I'd like to
invite all of our graduates their family
and friends to join us in a reception at
the GSB campus next door I look forward
to seeing you there as well as
tomorrow at the University commencement
exercises thank you and good afternoon
you
a mama Tay quiero mandar un gran saluez
daca ya t tambien papa Yoho celui mi
suegra a natalia ya todo lo que me estan
viendo el señor de ser por todo por todo
lo que hecho por me y un riservati mama
ciao
hello this is Victor 1 i'm a slum fellow
2009 of stanford graduate school of
business today I'm so excited receiving
my master degree management as well as
my global management certificate and my
property managements addicted special
thanks to my wife Jenny I would not be
standing here today without your great
support to my little daughter Colleen I
love you too my parents-in-law my friend
Miss jacala who came over here today for
my graduation thank you my parents I
know you're watching the webcast now
thank you to my classmates faculties
relatives and friends who helped and
support me through this life-changing
Stanford's long experience Thank You
Stanford I'm proud of you thank you
you
hey I'm that Imam is a pity that you
can't come to my graduation ceremony
from China but I know you're watching
you're watching that from from computers
and then I just want to see thank you so
much for all your support during my
study and without you guys I can't
really finish this and then I want to
speak this in Chinese out for like five
seconds um Papa mama watch it out
nimhans ethnic abajo sitting in the chi
Chi host and girls in my email so that
mom I love you so much thank you so much
by mine she seeing a beanie cheers
Cheers Sabrina's boys oh hell is insane
sonic no silly i perceive a cinco seis y
su muito grad prophecy stray luma na
Damian vida todo Sicario apoyo llamo o
SG mesmo loans acenta closest on kiddo
malad me puedes ella Brandis momento de
menthe allegria by my go straight
jagrata services in special cuando
scrimmage ariston by stanford emits
Creevy como tendo's oil smell Piper
wound you corazon de Mia my prospectus
boys hace que debe muito mais key
services el Divo to davao says no tomas
palabras Odysseus em wit muy muy to
brigade a woman went overseas
hi family wisely leash Jodi Renee thank
you so much for watching I am feel very
loved it feels bloody good to be finish
we are going to go and have some
champagne now happy birthday Sandra and
Mark sorry for disappointing you with
the RJ Miller but um that was never
gonna happen I really didn't study
nearly hard enough love you all and
hopefully see your Seng hey